MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20 Special Relativity.
In this short
video, you're going
to see how special
relativity, here shown as SR,
fits into the general
landscape of physics theories.
Very likely you have listened
to 8.01 last semester
or some previous time
in your career at MIT.
And once we enter the discussion
of special relativity,
it might seem to you
that what you learned
there was simply incorrect.
A better way to look at this
is that each of those physics
theories, they have
a range of validity,
a range in which the
theory works and describes
physical phenomena.
And so here in this
picture, I'd like
to point out that even
special relativity has
its own range of validity.
But let's start with
classical mechanics.
So classical mechanics
describes the motion
of objects, a collision of
objects, a rotation of objects.
In 8.02, you are
studying electrodynamics.
But you do that typically at MIT
in those courses at velocities
which are modest--
small velocities,
small velocities
compared to the speed of light.
Once you accelerate,
once you have velocities
which are really, really large,
then the description breaks.
The validity of those
theories breaks.
And that's where special
relativity comes in.
And it's especially
important when
you discuss very fast moving
bodies, fast moving reference
frames, or behavior of light.
And so this is what
special relativity does.
The range of validity is
basically fast-moving phenomena
with high speed.
But special relativity
by itself doesn't
help you to understand,
for example,
object of small scales.
In order to have a
proper description here,
you need to study
quantum mechanics.
If you have object
of very mass large
or with large
accelerations, you need
to enter a generalized
view, general relativity.
And if you, for example,
combine high velocities
and small scales, you have to
study quantum field theories.
So the point of
this slide is really
to point out that special
relativity has a specific use
case.
It's limited.
It describes
fast-moving objects.
It doesn't describe
large accelerations.
So that is the
generalization you get when
you study general relativity.
So in summary,
special relativity
is a complete description
of physical phenomena
at high speed.
It is consistent
with 8.01 and 8.02.
And you will later see that
whenever we find integration
of motion for object
at high speed,
if we use smaller
velocities, we'll
find the solutions
of 8.01 and 8.02.
When we combine
special relativity
with quantum mechanics,
it describes quantum field
theories.
And as I was saying,
the generalization
of special relativity, SR,
is general relativity, GR.